now uh one of the candidates who took a
lot of heat tonight was a relative
newcomer to the Republican Party
self-described Outsider take a look
so first let me just address a question
that is on everybody's mind at home
tonight
who the heck is this skinny guy with a
funny last name and what the heck is he
doing in the middle of this debate stage
I'm not a politician Brett you're right
about that I'm an entrepreneur my
parents came to this country with no
money 40 years ago I have gone on to
found multi-billion dollar companies I
did it while marrying my wife apoorva
raising our two sons following our faith
in God that is the American dream
and I am genuinely worried that that
American Dream will not exist for our
two sons and their generation unless we
do something about it and I do think
Brett is going to take an outsider
because for a long time we have
professional politicians in the
Republican Party who have been running
from something now is Our Moment to
start running to something to our
video what it means
[Applause]
[Music]
you hand it over to a new generation to
actually fix the problem that's why I'm
in this race and we're just getting
warmed up
all right vivec uh ramaswamy Vivek I've
been calling you vivec why didn't you
correct me I didn't know well you know
Sean that's okay it's like cake okay you
should have told me I appreciate that I
didn't do it on purpose I appreciate
best time all right so it was
interesting tonight I thought you were
in an interesting position you brought a
lot of energy and a smile and you seem
to be having fun up there uh I'm the
only one on stage not bought and paid
for ouch uh I thought they were they
were coming after you pretty good uh
Christy came back at you and said oh
okay
um you know compared you to Barack Obama
a guy with a long last name and liberal
you know obviously yeah and I I
encourage Chris Christie to give me a
hug because he did that to Barack Obama
and that actually unfortunately charm
for Barack Obama but the reality is
everybody on that stage had been on a
debate stage before this is my first
time in a political debate and I am
thrilled with how it came out we over
exceeded my expectation frankly even
Trump in as an outsider last time around
I think his second debate was a lot
better than his first right frankly this
this one way better than that I think
obviously one of the reasons is you're
very media Savvy you have a group you
have a warm
enticing personality and smile
politicians don't smile enough they need
to smile more I'm not a politician and
honestly it was fun okay you're now
officially a politician months into
being a political yeah you're in you're
six months once you're in tonight okay
officially I'm gonna have to cringe but
wear that label but I do think Sean is
going to take an outsider I do not think
whether it's ending the war in Ukraine
whether it's Reviving this economy and
the war that I really do want to fight
is the war on the administrative State
and the shadow government here at home
that is not going to happen from
somebody who comes from the Super PAC
class it's not going to come from
somebody who comes from the historical
Republican party it is going to take an
outsider and the other thing Sean that I
think is really important in this
election is that we're skating on thin
ice this has to be a moral mandate this
cannot be another 50.1 election and I'm
in this race to build a multi-ethnic
working class last majority like Reagan
did this has to be a landslide young old
black white hispanic man woman doesn't
matter I'm running this campaign that
way we're going to the south side of
Chicago to Kensington in the inner city
of Philadelphia where Republican
candidates are taught not to go in a
primary no but the reality is that's why
I don't mention Republicans and
Democrats on the stage and I'm a little
different than the other candidates here
because everybody else was focused on
Joe Biden and I think Joe Biden's a
disastrous president but I think the way
we win in a landslide is we have to
offer an independent vision of our own
and the more we do that the more likely
we are to win there were a few shots
it's not a time for on the job training
yeah you don't have that background that
experience you have an impressive
personal story talking about your
parents my parents my mom was a prison
guard my dad really waited tables on
weekend and was a family court probation
office look at where you are now you
know by the way they don't believe it
and they're in heaven so uh they're
looking down saying God how did that
happen yeah my mom thought be on the
other side of the prison
um well I think it's a remarkable but
it's a remarkable story that
story right the extraordinary thing
about our story Sean is that they're not
out of the norm they're normal in the
United States of America
are you confident that you can convince
the American people that you know what
I've got enough experience that can that
can take care of this country's needs
yes and that is my job in this race this
was the first chance that it really had
to introduce myself directly to the
people and I believe I will be the next
nominee I believe I will win the general
election in a landslide that reunites
this country
Donald Trump would you pardon the bidens
no I I mean it depends on I don't want
to be them right the real heart of the
problem with Joe Biden and Hunter Biden
is that I believe they're selling off
our foreign policy to make money and if
that's proven in a court of law they
should be in prison probably for the
rest of their life but I don't want to
be them so I will let the I want to see
an impeachment increase proceed and if
they're convicted in a court of law
absolutely they deserve full punishment
for that and the facts look pretty ugly
to me as they stand vague anytime I
mispronounce something you have every
right to correct me and I wish you would
have earlier because uh but I appreciate
your good sense of humor thank you
appreciate being with us thank you all
right hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else